- Have a seat!
You look so cool!
- Thank you!
Thanks, I'm trying it.
- [Kelly] I love this fancy casual outfit.
- (laughing) Thank you.
- It's very nice.
- Honestly, it's just comfy.
- Did you go to a water
polo school, too? (laughing)
- No, my school did not have water polo.
- [Kelly] I know, we didn't either,
we were not that cool.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- You have a big birthday coming up, 30!
- I do!
- That's exciting.
- The big 3-O.
- Yeah!
- I know.
- I get excited.
I'm like a decade older than you,
so I'm almost 40,
and so it's a big
birthday year for me too.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- Do you get excited about it
and plan stuff?
- I am, yeah.
People have asked me like,
"Are you scared?"
"Like 30, you know, that's different-"
- No, it's great.
- But yeah, I feel good.
- Yeah.
- I'm looking forward to it.
And yeah, I love birthdays.
- I feel like my 20s were so fun,
like, I did a lot of cool stuff
in my career, but like-
- Yeah.
- they were hard overall.
- Like growing-wise.
- Yeah.
- So, I was excited for 30.
I'm looking forward to like,
that next chapter in life.
- That's exciting.
- Yeah.
- That's awesome.
So, you really get into
like, I heard wine.
And do you, you make
wine, did I hear that?
- I don't make wine myself-
- Okay.
- maybe in the future.
- I would love that, but yes-
- [Kelly] I wanna do the Lucille thing,
where you crush the grapes.
- I have done that.
- You have?
- [Taylor] Yes.
- [Kelly] Oh My gosh!
- Yes, this is at one
of our favorite wineries
in Paso Robles.
And we got to crush the grapes,
and like just see-
- You get into wineries like,
the whole tasting, everything.
- Yeah.
That's like my go-to thing now.
Like people ask me,
what do you want to do on your birthday?
- Yeah.
- Like big party?
I'm like, no, I just
want to like go to Paso,
go to Napa-
- Yeah,
with a nice charcuterie board-
- Chill.
Oh yeah.
- Yes.
- Love a charcute.
- Yeah, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- And just, yeah,
enjoy some wine.
- That's fun.
Are you like really good at it?
'Cause I'm always, I lie.
I'm like, "oh, the oak, yes."
"The vanilla, yes."
I'm like, I never taste what they're,
I don't have an experienced
palate or something.
I dunno.
- Yeah.
I'm getting better.
But, I definitely still like,
BS my way through it.
(Kelly laughs)
- You do?
- I'm like yeah,
notes of the cranberry and the-
- (laughing) Yeah, totally.
I totally felt autumn in my mouth.
(both laughing)
You're like, yeah.
But, is this photo from one
of your birthday parties?
'Cause this is, you look
terrified. (laughing)
- See, I don't even
remember where that's from,
but yeah, clearly you
can see it in my eyes.
- I will say Flip Flop the
Clown does look scary as hell.
(Both laughing)
- I mean, who likes clowns?
- Well, and that one particularly looks
like he might wear your skin.
- Flip Flop is-
- Yeah.
(both laughing)
He looks scary,
like he looks kinda scary.
- He's a little sketchy.
- Yeah.
- I do not trust him.
- I don't like clowns either.
I don't like, "IT" scared me.
- Yeah.
- I was the youngest in my household
and I was shown, is it "IT",
the movie with the clown, right?
- Yes.
- Yeah, that's what I thought.
Yeah, that scared the hell out of me.
- Yes.
- I was done with clowns.
- I do feel like I've
kind of overcome my fear
of clowns though,
because I've started,
I've been like really
into Halloween and like,
I throw a Halloween party-
- Yeah.
- have a bunch of people over.
- Costumes mandatory?
- Yes, costume is mandatory.
- Yes.
- And I love opening my party
with like a super scary entrance.
- Ooh.
- So, before you like,
walk onto the dance floor-
- People scare the crap
out of you?
- you gotta go
through the scary entrance.
- That says a lot about you.
- Yeah, and you bet yourself I
put a lot of clowns in there.
- (laughing) I love that.
- Filled with clowns.
- That's so funny.
You have an entrance, a hall of scary.
- Yeah.
- So, wait, you're engaged!
Congratulations!
- I am, thank you!
- That's exciting.
- This is my favorite thing
to learn about you though.
Her name is Taylor. (laughing)
- [Taylor] Yes.
- Like, what were the chances?
- We either keep it super
simple or super complicated.
- Okay, do you go by
Taylor and she goes by Tay?
- Yes.
- Okay, that makes it easier.
- Or a lot of people just
do boy Tay and girl Tay.
- (laughing) Oh my god!
Sounds like you are-
- They're like "Boy Tay"-
- in Montessori.
Like, pre-k
- Yeah.
but either Taylor and Tay
or boy Tay, girl Tay, whatever works.
- How did y'all meet?
- Funny story.
My sister actually introduced us.
- Oh, I love that.
- Yeah, my sister always-
- Your family approved first,
that's nice.
- Yeah.
It's just me and my sister.
So, we're super close.
And she always said,
that she was going to
introduce me to my future wife.
And I was like, sure.
- Oh my gosh.
- But, she actually did. Yeah.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah, she was like,
I have an idea.
Because I love game nights,
she's like, throw a game night,
invite me and some of my friends over,
and I'll bring Tay, she'll
just be one of them.
And you guys can just meet-
- Feel it out.
- Yeah, and-
- And it worked out.
- We hit it off
and the rest is history.
- She should start a company
of setting people up. (laughing)
- Right? Yeah, naturally.
- So, how did you end up proposing?
- You know, Tay is awesome
and this is one of the
things I love about her.
She's like, I don't want anything special.
I don't want anything grand.
- Aw.
- I just want to, like
do it in the kitchen.
Like, I love to cook,
so I make us dinner all the time.
And she's like, one night when
we're just like having dinner
and a glass of wine,
like that's all I want.
- Yeah.
- So, I did do it in the kitchen,
but I did it big in the kitchen.
I had it filled with flowers.
- I love that.
We have this picture and I mean-
- Oh, yes.
- what are we talking about
with the flowers and the fire?
(audience clapping)
I love it,
and it's like,
I love that you have the neon sign
and you're like, are
you into this last name?
(both laughing)
- Do you approve?
Because we already share one name.
- Yeah.
- This is gonna be
extra complicated.
- Oh my God,
I actually didn't think
about that until just now.
(Kelly laughing)
- I know.
We're literally going
to be the same person.
- Oh my God, that's amazing.
- It's ridiculous.
- I just thought of that.
- How narcissistic?
- It's amazing, it's great.
It'll be easier.
So, she shared this photo from when,
I don't know,
she must have been like
10-years-old and this is great.
'Cause everyone's into Twilight.
Everybody loves Twilight.
I actually loved the books
before the first movie even came out.
I thought it was good.
It was fun, and then I loved the movies,
but here's what I want to ask though.
Was she an Edward fan or a Jacob fan?
- That is the question.
- Was she-
- She was team Edward.
- (laughing) That's awesome.
- Yes, she was.
But, so she's made up for it.
I'm allowing her to make that mistake.
It's in her past-
- Yeah, we all have pasts.
- Yeah, so she's good now.
But, she was not team
Jacob, unfortunately.
- That's so funny, I love it.
All right-
- I still love her.
- Let's take a little...
It's a good thing.
And we're back.
(both laughing)
That was a look at his
new movie "Home Team".
You can watch it now on Netflix.
So, I saw the movie.
It's so great, but tell
everybody what it's about.
- It is actually based off
a true story of Sean Payton,
who is the coach of
the New Orleans Saints.
And he was suspended a year
from the NFL for "the scandal".
And he went back,
and moved back to his
small hometown in Texas
and ended up coaching his
son's pee-wee football team
for the year.
- Which is awesome.
- Brought them to the
state championship game.
It's an amazing true story.
I play the son's pee-wee football coach,
who ends up asking Sean
if he'll help coach the team with me.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah, it's a really-
- And it's such a feel good vibe.
- Yeah, it's like a modern,
silly, "Bad News Bears".
- Yeah, oh my God, love!
- Yeah.
- Yeah, who doesn't?
So, go watch it, you're gonna love it.
Did you play football as a kid?
- I did.
- You did?
- I started playing football
when I was really young,
and then I had to give
it up in high school,
'cause I just started
missing practices and stuff,
because I had started acting.
And I was like, you know, got a job,
and I missed practice
and a game here and there
and the coach was like,
that's not gonna fly.
- Yeah, same thing with me with singing.
- Really?
- I loved sports
and then I was like, you know what?
This one might work out more,
so I kept singing.
- Yeah, at the time,
I was devastated.
- It worked out.
We chose the right path.
(both laughing)
- We're here now.
(audience applauding)
- Yeah,
but it is devastating,
because it's such a fun thing.
Like, that's where I learned teamwork.
That's why I think I work well as a team.
Like, I think there's so
many things you learn,
even if you're not going to
be a professional player.
There's so many awesome
things you learn in sports.
- Great life Lessons.
- Yeah.
And when you posted this
video of you on stage
at the Kane Brown concert recently,
so how did this happen?
(Taylor laughs)
I love this.
- Kane's a buddy.
And you know, he invited
me out to the show
and I was like, absolutely.
And then when I get there, he's like,
would you want to come on?
He has a song called "Famous
Friends" and he's like,
would you want to come on stage for that?
And you know, kind of just,
I'm like, kind of just what?
Like, what am I supposed to do?
I don't sing.
(Kelly laughing)
- You're just gonna be a famous friend.
(both laughing)
- That's basically what I was.
- That's your job, yes!
- Because, I didn't sing.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, I can't dance.
I'm gonna just look so weird.
He's like, you got it, bro.
We did have a little tequila courage.
- Oh, he convinced you that way.
- Yeah,
he suckered me in with that-
- Yeah, liquid courage.
- and then I found myself on stage
in the middle of the Staples Center.
- It's kind of fun though-
- Oh, yeah.
- because people expect probably,
he does that probably,
if he, you know, has anybody,
and people expected it, it's fun.
- Yeah.
- And it's out of context.
People are like, wait, what?
- So random
- Yeah.
It's so fun though.
It's like a bonus for the concert.
So, it's cool that you did it.
- It was a good time.
And I'm just a huge fan of his,
so it was super cool for me.
- Yeah.
Oh God, he's doing so well, yeah.
Well, speaking of music,
so Olivia Rodrigo is a huge Twilight fan,
as is the world.
I love Olivia as well,
her records, so great.
And she said that Jacob's favorite song
off her album would be "Traitor",
which is, she's funny.
(both laughing)
'Cause it's funny.
- Do you agree?
- Yeah, I can see that.
I think if I had to choose one,
I think I've heard most of them,
she's crushing it these days.
- Oh my God, every song is so good
on the album, yeah.
- It's crazy.
She is radio.
- Traitor, that's funny,
'cause Bella, I was like, that's funny.
- Too soon.
- Yeah, (laughing)
is it too soon?
(Taylor laughing)
So, you still get a lot of fan mail.
So, here's one that you posted.
- Oh boy.
- Let's show this.
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh, yes.
- First of all,
if you're rocking that kind of body, boy,
I'll be doing those photos too.
(both laughing)
That's amazing.
- Here's my favorite
thing about that photo.
I'm not wearing anything-
- Except tennis shoes!
- but tennis shoes.
(audience laughing)
Like, what?
- [Kelly] Because, you wanna
take care of your feet.
- Yeah, yeah, I guess.
(Kelly laughing)
Love the shoes.
- This is amazing!
- Great touch.
- Oh my God, it's amazing.
Well, because of streaming,
everybody is starting to rediscover things
that were huge pop culture moments.
And even my seven-year-old daughter,
literally I found her watching Twilight,
which I love you,
but I had to turn it
off cause she's seven-
- Yeah.
- but I love the movies
and I'll let her watch
it when she's older,
but it's cool because you're
getting all these new audiences
and I think that's kind of interesting.
And I know that you had to
have had crazy passionate fans
back in the day.
You're probably getting even more now.
What's like a crazy story
from like a fan that happened?
- They're definitely more chill now,
because like you said,
it's like these younger
kids that are coming up
that are just starting to watch
Twilight for the first time.
But, I mean back in the
day there's, oh my gosh.
There's a list of just crazy memories and-
- I can't imagine-
- and fan experiences from,
you know, being in Brazil
and having thousands of
fans break into our hotel
and they had to call the
Brazilian National Guard
to get them out.
- What?
- These are very passionate fans.
I mean, it's why the books
and movies are so successful.
It's these fans, they don't give up.
They get what they want.
- I loved the books and movies.
I would never break into your hotel room.
There are normal fans.
(both laughing)
Like, there are people that
just appreciate the arts,
but I was thinking that we
could maybe play a little game.
- Okay.
- A little Twilight game.
Are you into it?
- Oh, yeah. Heck yeah.
- Okay. I feel like I
might kick your behind.
I kept a daytime.
(Taylor laughing)